and action why are you not in the car
this young man wants to be an actor too
anyway I'll never forget what Geena
Davis said to me on the set of Stuart
Little
either you go or I go Lorraine I will
give you $100 if you go sit in the car
whoa it's ten times more than what I got
paid to come here you did this for $10
well five after taxes for after my agent
three after my manager so three $3 you
should go to law school you know I think
I could actually live here
whoa this is moving a little fast oh no
III didn't mean them here here I just
met chill okay
it's teachers you bitches know how how
could you do this to me Elijah go back
to the dance please stay out of this
Jeremy haven't you done enough for one
night again you need to call me mr.
DeLong pre-ind you I told you my dreams
we danced together
did that mean nothing to you I don't
know how to answer that
typical goodbye Carrie dubeck but just
tell me one more thing before I go
was that really 9-1-1 on the phone for
you no some moment we've all been
waiting for
he's got hundreds of millions of views
on YouTube and tonight he's performing
live with this song that made him famous
give it up for Chase sorry again he's
lip-synching
okay did the DJ have the right track for
him to sing to I'm assuming so
Streeter said he was taking care of the
singing
I am so sorry for what's about to happen
your 50 age of 10 I knew that I was bad
my whole like you
tired
[Music]
ah
seems okay that's it thank you so much
you guys have been so great I'm so happy
to be here but I have to go I'm gonna
meet little Wayne can you believe it
little Wayne okay well I am so lucky
thank you
good night you told me you were gonna
have a lip sync we didn't look like a
trash but we promised the live
performance hey Brooke we're leaving now
yeah you're done you go sit in the car
and don't talk but I want to dance these
kids are fine I'm sorry bud but you know
you'll have plenty dances to go to when
you get to high school
I'm not going to high school I already
graduated on Streeters phone yeah oh no
that was that was just the eighth grade
no he went through all high school too I
mean this guy told hork through the app
he's a smart little dude
hey I want you go say goodbye to your
date and then we'll meet little Wayne no
no he's not going to that he's staying
here oh no can do chica I mean I burned
a lot of bridges to get in that invite
so it would be poor form if you didn't
show up well he's not gonna show so why
don't you do your job for the first time
tonight and figure it the gout Oh who's
that
that's my sister yeah Durr
I meant the guy in all white with the
Kangol oh that's nobody okay boss yeah I
hear you I admit I had a few missteps
tonight but I think there's one thing
that we can agree that I did not mess up
and that's Lorraine her entrance was
perfect and she's been sitting out in
the car all night just like we asked her
to so because we're gonna do I'm gonna
have Lorraine come to the tequila party
put on sunglasses in the hoodie and a
little Wayne will never notice and then
chase can have his night off streeter
that's that's an amazing idea I'm sorry
I yelled at you you really you saved the
night thank you oh thank you and I
promise I will I will not mess up again
okay okay take the night off you really
think that's gonna work
no she's a 50-something year-old woman
but the boss a few hours driver take us
to little Wang
you